check it out the director Drew Goddard
and Kristen Connelly signed my Stephen
King book stuckman eyes the cabin in the
woods has gotten a lot of buzz and I
have heard so many great things about
this movie it was huge in the South by
Southwest festival heard all different
type of thing like you had to see this
movie you must in this movie it's so
different stay away from all the
trailers just going completely blind and
you will love this movie
and even though that's kind of exciting
at the same time it's a little bit
disheartening because I hate hyping
myself for things because a lot of times
it leads to disappointment I don't like
doing that so I try to kind of stay away
from that this movie is directed by Drew
Goddard and written by him and Joss
Whedon that's pretty awesome that's
awesome just let me know and Drew
Goddard is a really nice guy too I got
to talk with him for a while at the
screening he was really cool and so is
Kristen Connelly she was really nice
this movies like horror comedy it's
about this group of teenagers who go to
the cabin in the woods and they get
sucked into this world that's all I'm
gonna say
do not read plot points in this movie
just go in completely blind and you will
probably love this movie if you're a
horror fan like I am cuz I love this
movie this is one of the coolest horror
movies I have seen in a long time this
movie stars Chris Hemsworth Kristen
Connelly as well as some other stars
also Richard Jenkins and the dude from
Billy Madison the dude from Billy
Madison is awesome in this movie he is
so funny this movie is hilarious
it is able to spook the horror genre or
so effectively it's not like a spoof
like a scary movie type spoof it's more
of a tongue-in-cheek like wink to other
horror films it knows the corny parts of
horror films and it pokes fun at that
but at the same time it is also one of
the most inventive scary movies I've
seen in a long time you can imagine some
sort of movie monster that you've seen
before in a movie it's probably in the
cabin in the woods the movies kind of a
three-act show it starts off and you're
thinking boy this is just like any other
horror film I've seen before in fact
it's a hundred percent exactly like any
other horror film I've seen before the
second act is when stuff hits the fan
you're like what's going on the third
act is just like holy crap I did not
expect that at all that was amazing if
you are fan of scary movies if you think
that they're corny but you love them
this is the movie for you this movie is
seriously one of the coolest movies I've
seen in a while one of the best movies
of the year it had actors who understood
exactly what they were doing they knew
exactly where there
going with this movie they knew when to
be corny that knew when to be serious
great direction excellent writing I
can't wait to watch it again very few
problems with this movie not even worth
even mentioning honestly the movie looks
fantastic as well and the special
effects are awesome the cabin in the
woods gets an a-minus for me I really
suggest you see it when it comes out on
April 13th and as always if you liked
this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck mine eyes and all
this talk about being in the woods makes
me want to go for a hike I think I'm
gonna go for a hike you want to come
with me come on let's go
[Music]
what the tall fella like you doing on my
property huh damn near scared my
skeleton to death
oh you're cursed at men I know you hey
you want to come on inside
I just made some roast beef and we can
watch reruns of Roseanne that's right
big fella why don't you come on in and
stuckman eyes my face what
[Music]